oh hey I didn't see you there
hey it's Halloween you know a lot of
people wouldn't consider dragon ball is
the kind of show that would be scary but
nothing and I mean nothing can prepare
you for this boo gives me chills every
time no I could hear you saying mark
it's it's it's a comedy it's a cartoon
it's kids show back then standards for
what qualified as a kids show were a lot
more lenient how many people here
accidentally got watership down as a
gift off their parents it seemed
harmless enough just a heartwarming
adventure about bunnies right wrong
blood everywhere all the bunnies died
and on top of that Dragon Ball is a
Japanese so you know there's some
fucked-up [ __ ] buried in there somewhere
and lucky for you I've done the digging
so sit back relax grab a chair but not
in that order it'd be kind of weird if
was in that order you know I mean like
sitting down and then getting up to get
a chair again this is awkward sit back
and enjoy my top eight scariest Dragon
Ball moments number eight now some of
you might think I'm kidding here but
trust me I'm not this this covers every
major moment that scared me throughout
the whole series and this intrigue
legitimately scared me
you see Dragon Ball super was a show I
had been waiting for since I was a
little kid the ending to Dragon Ball Z
was kind of unsatisfying let's not even
talk about GT some things are just too
horrifying even for this list besides we
don't talk about fanfiction over here on
totally not mark now when Dragon Ball
super began I was a little nervous but I
was enjoying myself however what Episode
five came along
[Music]
oh sweet baby Jesus kill it Kelly went
fire this clip makes the list purely
because it made me think
Dragonball was over before it even began
again number seven you thought we fox
are dying in the Lion King was tragic
check trunks out almost all of his
mother's friends are dead almost all of
his family are dead he never even got to
meet his father
the only chance of a better world in his
eyes was going and to tell you the truth
this is one of the more tragic moments
in the entire series but that didn't
detract from the chill I felt when I
first saw Gohan lying there face down in
a pool of water all the wild trunks
trying to make sense of what's just
after happening something about how they
depict the androids in this timeline
made me feel as though they could have
been around any corner at any time
watching from afar ready to pounce it's
definitely an unsettling scene and one I
haven't forgotten since I first saw it
as a kid
number 6 it's very much the case in
every arc of Dragonball that the stakes
are never quite as high as they should
be comparatively to any other show under
the same conditions this is primarily
due to those little orange spheres
called Dragon Balls of which the show is
named after for those of you who don't
know these little orbs are for all
intensive purposes the control Z of the
anime world anything goes wrong anything
at all and boom outcomes Shenron the
magic dragon who can fix anything that
was of any consequence in the episodes
prior now I know what you're thinking
TNN that destroys tensions and ruins
everything
but when this episode aired the
magnitude of what happened hit me in
waves three waves to be exact
the first being Bullman dies that was
significant because it was the first
instance in the show's long history that
that had happened we're talking like 500
episodes of story here people die in
Dragon Ball all the time the second wave
that hit me was much stronger that was
that trunks and his timeline don't have
Dragon Balls suddenly the stakes are so
much higher and you begin to sympathize
with trunks is character the third and
final wave that hit me was chilling it
was in that moment I realized that Bulma
a woman who had lost everything from her
best friends to her family to even her
husband the last thing she saw before
she died was her oldest friend murdering
her number 5 all right we're at the
halfway point what we got next
this scene specifically from the ocean
tub to this day sends shivers down my
spine
you can forget childhood adult me is
scared of vegeta in this scene I defy
anyone to find a single moment where
you'd be more terrified of Vegeta
this is Vegeta's response right after he
finds out that Gohan stole the
Dragonball that he just stole and
naturally he's a little annoyed but at
least he's using his words though that's
important perfect if you're telling me
that this doesn't intimidate you even a
little bit then you're a filthy liar
that deserves to die in trunks is
timeline alright that's a little too
harsh spend the night with mr. Popo
[Music]
number 4
[Music]
what there's nothing now
like literally nothing everything that
there ever was in his timeline doesn't
exist anymore what kind of ending is
this maybe I'm getting a little too
ahead of myself here maybe they'll find
a way to fix it so yeah it's even worse
happy holidays everybody
what kind of ending is this was this
supposed to give closure
this is [ __ ] awful everything they
fought for it's gone
and now trunks has to live with an
altered version of himself I'm actually
speechless number three I didn't want to
have to watch this again but I did it
for you this is easily one of the
weirdest most fucked-up things I've ever
seen in Dragonball like you know what a
snake eats their food and their head
gets all stretched out now imagine that
snakes an ugly green old guy he's
vomiting up his food and you're an
eight-year-old kid trying to watch this
[ __ ]
it's a children's cartoon cartoons are
for kids if it's a cartoon it's fine he
craps an egg out of his face in case you
missed it it's there see it right there
right there you see I think it's an egg
coming out of his [ __ ] face number
two all right so this next one is pretty
well known it's widely considered the
most terrifying mode that all of
Dragonball this is like something
straight out of a horror movie
everything from the initial shot of
clothing dotted throat in abandoned city
to the slower v-love cell utilizing his
silhouette and shadows to build suspense
oh and also this this is the type of
stuff nightmares are made out of you can
see his skeleton
maybe it's cell maybe it's the
mutilation or but you cannot deny the
feeling that this scene instills in
people a truly terrifying character with
an even more horrifying scene now I'm
sure that tons of you out there thought
that this was gonna be number one and it
almost was but there was still always
one more scene that stuck with me but
before we go on to our number one spot
let's take a look at some honorable
mentions
number one many of you out there might
not have actually seemed to see or even
know about this character to give you a
rundown this scene takes place towards
the end of Dragon Ball the original
series during the 23rd World Martial
Arts Tournament you know the one where
Goku fights piccolo for the first time
the scene involves tension hun and
mercenary Tao who is looking
significantly more robotic than we last
saw in this confrontation is significant
because of tiens history with town much
the same way that Goku train under
master roshi tien and shouts to as
children trained in the crane school
however it differed by being far more
brutal and straight-up abusive the man
in charge was master [ __ ] but it's his
brother Tao that really takes the cake
here during this scene we get flashbacks
to mercenary tau beating down tension on
as part of his training and through
internal dialogue with tau we see just
how truly evil and remorseless he is for
his actions he comes off as this twisted
narcissistic blowhard initially but when
CN informs him that he is no match for
him now and that he'd prefer for him to
give up so as not to embarrass him
things get a little dicey backed into a
corner by tension hun tau removes his
hand and leaves behind him after
revealing a hidden blade he slashes at
Yin leaving him scarred for the rest of
his life I'm not sure what freaked me
out more in this scene it could very
easily have been a typical Dragon Ball
fight but something about that insane
laughs the hidden knife and Tau's design
overall is just frightening to me I
think is the fact that this interaction
between tau and Tien at its core is
something that could be replicated in
real life very easily someone trying to
cause a huge amount of harm to another
because they are just psychotic it's
sort of like The Scream movies in that
Tao is just a cold-blooded murderer
plain and simple
something very real in today's world
Dragon Ball has tons of battles with
hatred being the motivator for each
character but in all honesty this one
for me will always be the scariest
moment than all of Dragon Ball now if
you'll excuse me I have the next episode
of super to watch hey guys thanks for
watching and happy Halloween this video
and the documentary I made about Dragon
Ball super all had music created and
remix by this really cool dude right
here Adrien Martin if you enjoyed the
music
to Adrienne's social medias are down
below in the description so show him
some love
and if you'd like to follow me on
Twitter I'll leave that down there too I
sort of got one recently and if that's
still isn't enough maybe you'd want to
try every difference in Dragon Ball Z
abridged that was a fun one to make or
how about every Dragon Ball super
episode reviewed in ten words or less
take your pick
I hope you guys liked the video as
always thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one
happy Halloween